[Música]
el ejército y los paramilitares de Sudán
pactan un nuevo cese al fuego esta vez
mediado por Estados Unidos La tregua
durará tres días para acelerar las
evacuaciones que ya comenzaron Egipto
confirmó que uno de sus diplomáticos
murió en medio de los enfrentamientos en
canciller ruso cercaron la reunión de
este lunes en el Consejo de Seguridad de
la ONU sin embargo Rusia fue acusada de
violar los principios de la carta de
Naciones Unidas el secretario general
del organismo Antonio Gutiérrez le
propuso a Moscú que extienda el acuerdo
de grados
uno de los presentadores estrella de Fox
news dejó la cadena estadounidense su
salida se produce una semana después de
que el canal de noticias pactara un pago
por más de 787 millones de dólares
condominio en boaching systems para
evitar un juicio por difamación
bienvenidos Estas son las noticias de
France 24 y yo soy María Clara calle
iniciamos en Sudán donde hacen un nuevo
intento de tregua con la mediación de
Estados Unidos El cc comienza a media
noche hora local y se espera que dure
tres días los paramilitares de las
fuerzas de apoyo rápido confirmaron que
lo aceptaron Mientras tanto continúan
las evacuaciones por parte de países
europeos además de Corea del Sur Arabia
Saudita Egipto entre otros además el
Ministerio de relaciones exteriores de
Egipto confirmó que el agregado
administrativo adjunto de su embajada en
jartum murió en medio de enfrentamientos
Aquí les contamos como el conflicto en
Sudán afecta a los países vecinos
el conflicto en Sudán pone en riesgo al
continente africano durante una sesión
del Consejo de Seguridad el secretario
general de Naciones Unidas Antonio
Gutiérrez urgió a los miembros del
órgano a maximizar esfuerzos para
restablecer la paz en Sudán
Gutiérrez expresó su preocupación por un
posible efecto dominó del conflicto en
los países de la región
desde el inicio de los combates el 15 de
abril cientos de personas han muerto y
miles han resultado heridas la violencia
debe Cesar se corre el riesgo de una
conflagración catastrófica dentro de
Sudán que podría envolver a toda la
región y más allá
cinco de los siete países que colindan
con Sudán tienen un pasado y presente
inestable el conflicto entre cristianos
y musulmanes dentro de la República
central africana y la presencia de más
de 100 grupos armados En diversas
regiones del Congo son algunas
situaciones que podrían escalar si los
enfrentamientos dentro de Sudán se
desbordan de sus fronteras el gobierno
de Chad otro vecino de Sudán anunció que
detuvo un contingente de 320 soldados
sudaneses que intentaron ingresar al
país una movida que hace real la
capacidad de expansiva del conflicto
las fuerzas de seguridad sudanesas
entraron a nuestra casa pero tomamos
todas las medidas para desarmarlas
tenemos más de 400.000 refugiados
sudaneses que llevan con nosotros desde
2003 si esto vuelve a ocurrir mañana ya
verán Qué consecuencias sufriremos en
este país
los bajos índices de desarrollo humano
el extremismo islámico y los miles de
desplazados por los distintos conflictos
africanos podrían hacer de la región una
olla a presión a punto de explotar una
trenza reunión tuvo el Consejo de
Seguridad bajo la presidencia rotatoria
de Rusia el canciller ruso sergei
convocó al encuentro para discutir lo
que llamó el multilateralismo efectivo a
través de la defensa de los principios
de la carta de la ONU sin embargo varios
países occidentales lo criticaron
afirmando que Moscú es el que viola la
carta atacando a Ucrania y ocupando
parte de su territorio labrov respondió
que es occidente el que socava la
diplomacia global el secretario general
de Naciones Unidas Antonio gu tiérrez
aprovechó para enviarle una carta al
presidente de Rusia Vladimir Putin en la
que le propone mejorar y expandir el
acuerdo que permite la exportación de
granos por el mar Negro un acuerdo que
expira el 18 de mayo y que Rusia ha
amenazado con no renovar escuchemos
enfrentamos crisis entrelazadas y sin
precedentes pero el sistema multilateral
está bajo mayor presión que en cualquier
otro momento desde la creación de las
Naciones Unidas las tensiones entre las
principales potencias están en un nivel
histórico al igual que los riesgos de
conflicto por desventura o error de
cálculo la invasión de Ucrania en
violación de la carta de Naciones Unidas
y el derecho internacional está causando
un sufrimiento y una devastación masiva
al país y a su pueblo y se suma a la
dislocación económica mundial provocada
por la pandemia del Coby 19 distinguidos
colegas como sucedió en la Guerra Fría
Hemos llegado a un umbral peligroso
posiblemente aún más peligroso la
situación se ha visto agravada por la
pérdida del multilateralismo y la fe en
él como agresión financiera y económica
occidente está destruyendo los
beneficios de la globalización cuando
Estados Unidos y sus aliados abandonan
la diplomacia y exigen que se aclaren
las relaciones en el campo de batalla
todo esto se hace en los pasillos de
Naciones Unidas que se creó para
prevenir los horrores de la Guerra el
Ministerio de relaciones exteriores de
China declaró en un comunicado que
respeta la integridad territorial de
todos los países así Beijing intenta
calmar las tensiones la Unión Europea
que desató el embajador chino en París
quien cuestionó la soberanía de los
países bálticos por haber pertenecido a
la unión soviética veamos el informe
mientras la guerra continúa en Ucrania y
cuando kiev se prepara para una
contrafensiva en primavera los
comentarios del embajador de china en
Francia han provocado la indignación de
toda Europa
en su aparición en el Canal de noticias
francés lci se negó a decirse La crimea
anexionada Era De hecho parte de Ucrania
luego pasó a decir que los países que
surgieron después de la caída de la
unión soviética no tienen estatuto
afectivo en virtud del derecho
internacional porque no hay ningún
acuerdo internacional que confirme su
condición de Naciones soberanas
estos comentarios ponen entre dicho no
sólo Ucrania sino a todas las antiguas
repúblicas soviéticas que surgieron como
naciones independientes tras la caída de
la unión soviética en 1991 El lunes los
líderes de las tres naciones bálticas de
la Unión Europea Estonia letonia y
lituania convocaron a los enviados de
China para que explicaran sus
comentarios
seguir una aclaración si ha cambiado la
posición de China sobre la independencia
y recordarle que no somos países
posoviéticos somos los países que fueron
ocupados ilegalmente por la unión
soviética el máximo responsable de
política exterior de la Unión Europea
josep borrell calificó de inaceptables
las declaraciones del enviado chino y
dijo que el bloque también quería una
explicación el lunes el Ministerio de
asuntos exteriores de Beijing trató de
calmar la polémica retractándose de los
comentarios del embajador la posición de
China sobre las cuestiones relevantes no
ha cambiado china respeta el estatus de
soberanía de los países de la antigua
Unión soviética tras la disolución de la
unión soviética no es la primera vez que
elu desata la polémica en 2021 se peleó
en las redes sociales con un
investigador francés al que llamó
pequeño matón y troll también ha
remitido contra un grupo de legisladores
franceses que se plantean viajar a
Taiwán que china considera parte de su
territorio
uno de los presentadores estrella de la
cadena estadounidense Fox news ya No
trabajará con la compañía se trata de
Tucker carlson quien lideraba un show
con su nombre y que presentó por última
vez el viernes pasado según informó el
canal Fox news no ofreció explicaciones
sobre las causas de las salidas de uno
de sus personajes más influyentes
carlson tenía una audiencia estimada de
tres millones de espectadores cada noche
y llegó a ejercer gran influencia sobre
el partido republicano su salida de Fox
news ocurre una semana después de que la
cadena llegara a un acuerdo por
787,5 millones de dólares condominio en
boutings para evitar seguir adelante con
un juicio por difamación dominion
acusaba a Fox de propagar
deliberadamente de información falsa
sobre el rol de sus máquinas de conteo
de votos en un desmentido fraude
electoral Durante los comicios de 2020
así se pronunció la compañía mediática
foxys media y toker Carson acordaron
separarse le agradecemos su servicio a
la red como anfitrión Y antes como
colaborador el último programa del señor
Carson fue el viernes 21 de abril Fox
news Tonight se transmitirá en vivo a
las 8 pm
y cerramos con noticias latinoamericanas
el ex presidente peruano Alejandro
Toledo y quien fue extraditado desde
Estados Unidos el pasado domingo no se
presentó este lunes a la audiencia de
control de acusación en esta le leían
precisamente los cargos que enfrentan
por lavado de activos Por presuntamente
recibir 35 millones de dólares en
sobornos por parte de la constructora
brasileña odebrecht Aunque el juez
recordó que Toledo no tenía la
obligación de asistir por ahora el
expresidente seguirá pagando 18 meses de
prisión preventiva en el penal de
barbadillo donde están los antiguos
mandatarios Alberto fujimori y Pedro
Castillo
así llegamos al final de las noticias
pero los invitamos a que consulten más
información en nuestra página web France
24.com también nos encuentran en las
redes sociales con arroba franz24-raya
al piso es sigan con nosotros Porque
volvemos en minutos
[Música]